The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
The goal is to count up all of
the valence electrons that you
have in a molecule and then
distribute those valence
electrons so that between each
two atoms there are at least two
electrons.
And then what you do is you
take the rest of the electrons
and distribute them around the
molecule, so that each atom has
an inner gas configuration
around it.
That's usually an octet,
unless you're dealing with
hydrogen.
That's the main idea.
And so what that means is that
you have to know what those
valence electrons are.
And so that is something that
you should get used to knowing,
so you could just really write
that down immediately.
But we also saw last time that
a very critical concept was this
concept here of formal charge.
Formal charge is a measure of
how much an atom has gained or
lost an electron when it has
formed a bond in a particular
structure.
And we saw how this idea of
formal charge was really
critical in being able to
determine what was the lowest
energy structure.
In fact, what was the lowest
energy skeletal structure.
Often times,
when you start out,
you don't know what atoms are
connected to each other.
You have to take a guess.
You take a guess.
You put out the Lewis
structure.
You draw out the Lewis
structure, and then you
calculate the formal charge.
And if you find on that Lewis
structure that any atom has a
formal charge,
a minus 2 or a plus 2 or minus
3 or plus 3, that cannot
possibly be the lowest energy
structure.
And then you start again.
You find another skeletal
structure, draw out the Lewis
diagrams, calculate the formal
charges.
And you keep doing that,
until you find a skeletal
structure that gives you the
lowest set or the lowest
absolute values of formal
charges.
This is a very important
concept.
That's how you do it.
Now, we also saw last time that
we were able to draw a couple of
different skeletal structures
where the set of formal charges
was the same.
Except that,
in those two different Lewis
structures, one structure had a
formal negative charge on an
oxygen, and the other one had it
on the nitrogen.
In that case,
we want to always make sure we
put the negative formal charge
on the most electronegative
element.
And then, finally,
in our discussion of formal
charge, we were talking about
this ion here,
NO3 minus.
And this formal charge concept
helped us to understand when we
had a resonance structure.
For example,
we did a Lewis structure that
looked like this.
And we put this double bond
here between one nitrogen and
one of the oxygens,
but we realized we could have
also put it between this
nitrogen and oxygen and we
realized we could have put it
between this oxygen and this
nitrogen.
And, of course,
in all three cases we've got
the same set of formal charges.
They look identical.
So what happens in this case?
Well, when you've got this
situation where it looks like
you've got three different
structures, and the formal
charges are the same,
well, this is a hint that you
have a resonance structure.
That is that these two
electrons here,
these two extra electrons are
not sitting between just one
nitrogen and an oxygen.
But rather these two electrons
are delocalized over all three
bonds.
That is to say,
these three bonds,
nitrogen-oxygen,
those three bonds are all
equivalent.
It is not the case where one of
the bonds is a double bond and
the other two are single bonds.
Rather, those extra two
electrons are distributed
equally over all three bonds.
And so each one of these bonds
kind of looks like a bond and a
third.
It's a little bit shorter than
a single bond and a little bit
stronger than a single bond,
but not as short as a double
bond and not as strong as a
double bond.
When you have this situation of
three sets, three different
structures, three different
Lewis structures but same set of
absolute values,
that's a clue you've got a
resonance structure.
Okay?
Yes?
No, the lone pairs here are
not.
They actually reside,
they're most close to the
actual atom that they're shown.
It's only the bonding electrons
that exhibit this
delocalization.
All right.
Now, what we want to do today
is I want to show you some
exceptions to the octet rule.
There are always exceptions.
And we started out saying that
these Lewis diagrams and the
octet rule, that worked 90% of
the time.
Now I want to show you the
other 10% when it actually
doesn't work.
And so here is the first
exception when it doesn't work.
It doesn't work when you have
an odd number of valence
electrons, because these Lewis
diagrams are based on the idea
that a bond shares,
a bond is composed of two
electrons, and those two
electrons are shared between the
two atoms.
And so, if you've got an odd
number of valence electrons,
this whole idea breaks down.
For example,
the methyl radical,
CH3 dot.
A methyl radical has an odd
number of valence electrons.
It has seven valence electrons.
It is because it has that one
unpaired electron that it's
actually really very reactive.
And so if you try to use your
Lewis rules that we had on this
kind of situation where you've
got an odd number of valence
electrons, everything really
just breaks down.
So if you're given a structure
to draw and you've got an odd
number of valence electrons,
forget it.
You really cannot use the octet
rule and then the Lewis diagrams
to do that.
You need a more sophisticated
scheme for looking at the
bonding of molecules which have
an odd number of valence
electrons.
And we're going to look at some
of those more sophisticated
schemes in a couple of days or
so.
So that's one exception.
But here comes a second
exception, and this is an
exception to the octet rule.
The octet rule is going to
break down, but we are still
going to draw a Lewis diagram.
And I will show you how.
The octet rule is going to
break down for these elements in
group 13.
The octet rule is going to
break down for boron,
aluminum, gallium,
indium in the group 13.
You come to a problem where
you've got to draw a Lewis
diagram for a group 13 element.
Do you know what should happen
in your mind?
Buzzers ought to go off,
buzz, buzz, buzz meaning
there's going to be an exception
here.
I mean this.
Really, if you see boron,
aluminum, you're on heightened
alert here.
Something unusual could happen.
Let me explain this.
Suppose we are writing the
Lewis structure for BF3,
we need the skeletal structure
first.
Well, I said last time that the
fluorines, they're just almost
always terminal atoms.
Good guess.
Put the boron in the center.
Now let's count up the number
of valence electrons.
Well, we have four atoms here.
Each of the three fluorines are
bringing in seven valence
electrons and the boron is
bringing in three.
We've got a total number of 24
valence electrons here.
I just drew them out.
Now we want to count up our
step three here,
the number of electrons that we
would have to have if each one
of these atoms had an octet
around it.
So we've got four atoms.
Each one wants eight.
So we would have to have 32
electrons.
To calculate the number of
bonding electrons in step four
we subtract the number of
electrons that we'd have to have
for an inner gas configuration
from the number of valence
electrons that we do have.
And that is eight.
And what I did last time is I
put a square here around the
valence electrons that are going
to be bonding electrons.
And our next step in the Lewis
diagram said we're going to
assign those bonding electrons,
two to each bond.
Let's do that.
Well, we just did it.
Here is two,
here is two,
here is two.
We used up six of the bonding
electrons.
And our next step says,
do we have any remaining
bonding electrons.
Well, yeah, we do.
We've got two bonding electrons
here that we haven't used.
And we said last time,
in this case what we usually
do, or what we do,
is that we assign those
electrons so that we have
multiple bonds.
We have a double bond.
For example,
we're going to choose one of
these boron-fluorine bonds and
put in another two electrons so
that we have a double bond
between the boron and the
fluorine.
That's what our rules said last
time, so let's follow them for a
moment.
So we did that.
Now we've used up all of our
bonding electrons.
Do we have any valence
electrons left?
We sure do.
Gobs of them.
We only used eight of them for
the bond so we've got 16 valence
electrons.
That means we're going to have
to make eight lone pairs.
And we distribute them around
each atom in the molecule so
that each atom has an octet.
So let's do that.
Here we've got eight around
fluorine, eight around this
fluorine, there's eight around
the boron and there is eight
around the fluorine.
Everything looks normal.
Everything looks great.
Now let's calculate the formal
charge.
That is something else we've
got to check.
Formal charge is number of
valence electrons minus the
number of electrons that are
lone pairs minus the number of
bonding electrons divided by 2.
Let's calculate that for boron
in this structure.
So we said boron has three
valence electrons.
How many lone pairs does boron
have in this structure?
How many lone pairs?
None.
They're all bonding electrons.
How many bonding electrons does
boron have?
Eight.
8 divided by 2 is 4.
The formal charge on this boron
is minus 1, so we're going to
put a minus 1 right there.
And then if you proceed to
calculate the formal charge on
this doubly-bonded fluorine
right here, you would find that
that formal charge was plus 1.
And if you go and you calculate
the formal charges on the singly
bonded fluorines,
you would find that that was 0.
So I will put a zero and a zero
there.
And now, remember,
last time we said that the sum
of those formal charges has to
equal the overall charge on the
molecule.
If it doesn't,
you've done something wrong
somewhere.
And so I just summed them up.
That sum is 0.
The overall charge on BF3 is 0.
We did things correctly.
But now when you look at this
you say, well,
this looks like NO3 minus,
in the sense that I
could have taken these two
electrons and put them in this
bond to make that structure.
If I did, I'd have the same set
of formal charges.
Or, I could have taken those
two electrons and put them right
here, like that.
If I did so,
I would still have the same set
of formal charges.
Look, this looks like one of
these resonance structures that
I just told you about.
That's what it looks like.
Why not resonance?
Well, why not?
Because this beeper is going
off in your head,
beep, beep, beep,
this is boron.
Boron is an exception.
Let me show you how it is an
exception.
Experimentally,
if you look at these
boron-fluorine bonds,
you would not see that there
would be one double bond and two
single bonds.
You would not find a
boron-fluorine bond that looks
like a double bond and two that
look like single bonds.
You would also not find that
these three bonds were a bond
and a third like in NO3 minus.
Experimentally,
you would find that these
boron-fluorine bonds all have
the same length,
but they are typical of a
single bond.
Unlike in NO3 minus where it
was a bond and a third,
these boron-fluorine bonds all
look like single bonds in terms
of their lengths,
in terms of their strengths.
Very different than NO3 minus.
Given that experimental
observation, what are we going
to do?
Well, we're going to write a
structure here where we're going
to give every atom in that
structure an octet,
except for the boron.
So what did I do?
I took the extra two electrons
here, removed it from the
boron-fluorine bond and gave it
just to the fluorine so that
every fluorine or every atom in
this molecule has an octet,
except for this outlier boron.
Still got the same number of
electrons, everything is fine,
but I moved these electrons
from here to the fluorine.
Let me calculate the formal
charge here.
If I do that,
I find that the formal charge
on boron is 0 now instead of
minus 1.
I find that the formal charge
on this fluorine is 0,
this fluorine is zero,
and this fluorine,
hey, that's 0.
I've got a structure with all
zero formal charges.
That is awesome.
[LAUGHTER]
The octet rule just broke down
here.
And that is the case for the
elements in group 13,
or that is oftentimes the case
for the elements in group 13.
In BF4 minus,
for example,
the octet rule doesn't break
down.
But in BF3, BCl3,
aluminum trichloride,
same thing.
The group 13 elements are octet
deficient.
So that's an exception that you
have to know about.
And, in fact,
this is the structure.
Experimentally we can tell
that.
And it's the lowest energy
structure.
We've got a set of zero formal
charges.
So that's group 13.
That is our second exception.
This just repeats that.
Great.
Now, here is our third
exception.
So we've got an exception now
where we don't put an octet
around some atoms.
And now this is the opposite
case.
The third exception is where
we're going to put more than an
octet around an atom.
We're going to call this
valence shell expansion.
And the example we're going to
use is phosphorus pentachloride.
Let's draw the Lewis structure
first, and then we will see how
our rules are going to kind of
break down.
For phosphorus pentachloride,
let's put the phosphorous in
the center because the chlorines
are usually terminal.
Not always but usually.
So let's start there.
We do that.
Let's calculate the number of
valence electrons.
Well, fluorine,
it brings in seven valence
electrons.
There are five of them.
Phosphorus, it brings five
valence electrons into the
party.
We've got 40 valence electrons.
How many electrons would we
have to have if we had an inner
gas configuration around each
atom?
Well, we've got six atoms.
6 times 8 is 48.
So what do our rules say about
the number of bonding electrons?
Well, our rules say that we've
got eight bonding electrons
because 48 minus 40 is 8.
Well, that's great.
Eight bonding electrons,
we can make four bonds.
But we've got a problem.
You can see already that we're
going to have to make at least
five bonds so we've got a
problem.
Our kind of formula here for
writing these Lewis structures
broke down.
It's clear we're going to have
to make ten bonds,
but in our procedure here it
let us make only four bonds.
So what are we going to do?
Fudge.
Good.
That's exactly what we're going
to do.
We're going to fudge.
We're going to forget our
rules.
We're going to draw five bonds,
each one to chlorine.
So now, of our 40 valence
electrons, ten of them have been
used as bonding electrons.
That means we've got 30 valence
electrons leftover.
We're going to have to
distribute them around the
molecule so that each atom,
except the phosphorus,
has an octet around it.
We will do that.
Here are six for that chlorine.
Now we used another six,
12 for that chlorine.
Another six for that chlorine,
18.
24.
Another six for that chlorine,
30.
We just used them all up.
Let's calculate the formal
charges.
The formal charge on phosphorus
is the number of valence
electrons on phosphorus,
which is zero.
Number of lone pairs on
phosphorus, which is zero.
And number of bonding electrons
divided by 2 on phosphorus.
Well, there are ten bonding
electrons.
2, 4, 6, 8, 10 divided by 2,
that's 5.
Formal charge on phosphorus is
0.
And now if you go and you
calculate the formal charges on
the chlorines,
they are all 0.
And we've got another awesome
looking structure here,
a set of zero formal charges
for phosphorus pentachloride.
That is very nice,
except for the fact that we've
got more than an octet around
the phosphorus.
The phosphorus has what we call
an expanded shell.
And that is the case,
that will be often the case,
for elements which have their
outermost electrons in a shell
where the principle quantum
number is 3 or greater.
Those elements have empty d
states.
Empty d states that can
accommodate more than eight
electrons, that can accommodate
more than an octet.
And phosphorus is one of those
elements.
So when you start to get to the
larger elements like phosphorus,
like the next example,
iodine, that I am going to show
you, we can put more than an
octet around those larger
elements.
Let's do another example here
with this valance shell
expansion.
Here is the IF4 minus
ion.
How do you draw,
first of all,
a skeletal structure?
What is a good guess for a
skeletal structure here?
Well, chlorines are always
terminal.
Let's put them on the outside
and the iodine in the middle.
Is there a question over there?
Can I help you out?
Any questions right now?
Okay.
Let's try it.
Let's count up the number of
valence electrons.
Well, we've got one,
two, three, four,
five atoms.
And they are halogens.
Halogens bring in seven valence
electrons.
Five times seven is 35.
But, and this is important,
we've got an extra charge here.
This is an ion.
It is minus one.
And so we're going to have to
add one to the number of valence
electrons.
We've got 36 valence electrons.
Now, the number of electrons of
each had an octet,
so that would be 40,
because we have five.
5 times 8 is 40.
According to our rules then,
the number of bonding electrons
is 40 minus 36 which is 6.
Which is 4.
[LAUGHTER] It's 4.
But what do we need?
We need eight bonding
electrons, because we've got to
make four bonds.
Here again, we have a breakdown
in our rules.
Something is wrong.
We are going to have to fudge,
as somebody said.
We're going to ignore our
rules.
We've got to make eight bonds.
Oh, jeez.
We've got to make four bonds so
we need eight electrons.
Let's make them.
There they are.
So we used eight of the valence
electrons as bonding electrons.
36 minus 8 is 28.
We've got 28 remaining valence
electrons or 14 lone pairs.
We're going to distribute them
around that fluorine.
There are 6,
that fluorine,
there is another 6,
and that's 12.
That fluorine is 18.
This fluorine is 24.
We just used up 24 of those
valence electrons,
but we haven't used them all.
We've got four valence
electrons remaining.
Where are they going to go?
Well, where we are going to put
those four remaining valence
electrons are around the iodine
right there.
We're going to give them to the
iodine, and the iodine is going
to have two lone pairs.
So the iodine here has four
more electrons around it.
And we can do that,
again, because the iodine has
got some empty 5d states that
can accept these electrons,
and it does.
Everything has got an octet
here, except for the iodine.
Let's check the formal charges
and make sure we did everything
correctly.
Calculate the formal charge on
iodine.
Well, number of valence
electrons, seven.
Minus the number of lone pairs.
Look at how many lone pair
electrons we have on the iodine,
two, four.
We've got four lone pair
electrons on iodine.
Minus one-half the number of
bonding electrons on iodine.
Well, we've got eight bonding
electrons.
Here they are,
two, four, six,
eight.
These red ones don't count.
They are the lone pairs.
8 over 2 is 4.
The formal charge on iodine is
minus 1.
If you go and you calculate the
formal charges on fluorine,
they are all zero.
Some of those are minus 1.
That is indeed the overall
charge on this iodine
tetrafluoride.
So we did it right.
Here is another case where
there is an octet around each
one of the atoms,
except for that larger atom,
the iodine, which has actually
two, four, six,
eight, ten, twelve electrons
around it.
Yes?
No, these aren't d electrons
necessarily.
These are in empty states here.
There is plenty of room even to
put some more in the case of
iodine.
We saw that these Lewis
diagrams, the octet idea works
90% of the time,
but three exceptions.
An odd number of electrons?
Forget it.
You cannot use it.
We're going to find some more
sophisticated models for
bonding.
It doesn't work on group 13.
Group 13 elements often have
less than an octet.
And then, finally,
if you get to the heavier
elements like iodine,
like phosphorus,
that we looked at,
like chromium is one example in
the notes that I didn't work
through.
But you will work through that
in recitation.
You've got some empty d states.
You can put more than an octet
around those heavier atoms.
So that is what I wanted to say
here about the Lewis diagrams.
And next, on Friday we're going
to start looking at a little bit
more sophisticated model for
chemical bonding,
which is molecular orbital
theory.
But right now,
what I want to do is I want to
talk about one other kind of
classical model for chemical
bonds.
It is a model that works only
for a very ionic bond,
like sodium chloride.
That is what we're going to
talk about here.
And, in particular,
it's a model that is simple but
accurate in terms of giving us a
physical picture of actually how
this chemical bond forms.
Let's talk about it.
We're going to talk about the
formation of a bond between a
sodium atom and a chlorine atom.
How does this happen?
Well, we've got sodium and
chlorine coming together.
What happens here is this
sodium ejects an electron and it
spears the chlorine,
and that electron now is stuck
on the chlorine.
And so now the chlorine is Cl
minus.
It's pretty big.
Sodium is Na plus.
It's small.
And once that happens that
sodium just ropes that chlorine
right in.
It just pulls it right into it.
It is called the harpoon
mechanism.
Now, once that electron jump
happens of course these two ions
come together.
What is this rope in between
the sodium plus and the chlorine
minus?
Well, that rope is the Coulomb
interaction, right?
Because once that electron has
jumped from sodium to the
chlorine, we have a positive
charge and a negative charge.
And they are attracted.
And they just zoom right in
together until you get to the
bond length, and they form a
chemical bond.
That is literally what happens.
The sodium ejects an electron.
That jumps to the chlorine,
and then the two just zoop
right into each other and form a
chemical bond,
called the harpoon mechanism.
This is a mechanism here that
was really shown experimentally
by Dudley Herschbach here at
Harvard in the Chemistry
Department, John Polanyi in
Toronto and Yuan Lee in U.C.
Berkeley.
And for this mechanism and for
many other dynamics of chemical
reactions they got a Nobel Prize
in 1986.
And Yuan Lee over here was
actually my thesis advisor at
Berkeley.
This seems like a very peculiar
kind of way for a chemical bond
to form, but,
in fact, it is accurate.
Let me talk about the
energetics here of this process,
because that will help in
trying to understand physically
really what is going on in this
bond formation.
Because the first thing you're
saying is, well,
when that electron jumps,
that costs energy.
We know that.
We know that for a sodium atom
to remove an electron here,
that there is an energy cost,
delta E.
That energy cost is what
physically?
The ionization energy.
That's the ionization energy.
That's 496 kilojoules per mole.
But it is also true,
that once that electron gets in
the vicinity of chlorine,
the chlorine grabs it.
That is the chlorine plus the
electron here.
When that happens some energy
is released to make the chlorine
minus.
That energy,
delta E, is minus the electron
affinity.
That was one of the definitions
that we worked on a few days
ago.
And minus the electron affinity
there is minus 349 kilojoules
per mole.
So you get some energy back
when that electron attaches to
the chlorine.
But, overall,
if I sum things up here with a
sodium gas phase atom and a
chlorine gas phase atom going to
sodium plus plus Cl minus ,
the delta E for this
reaction here overall is still
positive 147 kilojoules per
mole.
You still have to put some
energy into this system to make
this reaction go.
And, of course,
this delta E here,
I used the number 147.
I added these up.
But delta E also can be written
here as the ionization of sodium
minus the electron affinity of
chlorine.
But it's still uphill to get
the electron to go from sodium
to chlorine.
However --
-- the sodium and the chlorine
now, once they are two ions and
they come together,
we're going to have some energy
released, because we're going to
form a bond.
Sodium plus plus chlorine minus
going to sodium chloride,
well, the delta E for that
reaction is minus 592 kilojoules
per mole.
Then, overall,
I am going to add up this
reaction to that reaction,
so these are going to cancel.
We have sodium gas phase plus
chlorine gas phase to make
sodium chloride.
That is the initial reaction we
were looking at,
sodium and chlorine to make a
sodium chloride molecule.
Overall, that delta E is minus
445 kilojoules per mole.
Overall, the action is
releasing energy.
And that is good but things
still seem a little strange,
right?
It still seems a little strange
that this sodium is ejecting an
electron and that chlorine is
grabbing it and then they come
together.
This ejecting of an electron is
a little bothersome so let's
look a little more carefully at
what is going on.
An energy level diagram.
Those are the energetics.
And now I am going to put those
energetics that I just described
onto a diagram to try to make it
a little bit more realistic for
you.
What I drew here is the energy
of interaction for sodium plus a
chlorine atom.
This is the same shape that I
drew for two hydrogen atoms.
It's the same shape because
whenever two atoms come together
to form a bond,
the energy of interaction looks
like this.
This is a general phenomenon.
Way out here the two atoms are
separated.
The energy of interaction is
zero.
As they come together,
there is an attractive
interaction.
The energy gets lower.
It continues to get lower until
we get to some value which is
the bond length.
It is at this point,
this value of r that you have
the most stable configuration.
This is the chemical bond.
You push them closer together.
The energy goes back up.
And then this well depth here,
from here to here or backwards
from down here to up here.
From down here to up there,
that's the bond association
energy delta E sub d.
In this drawing,
I reversed it.
I went from here to here.
It is minus delta E sub d.
It's minus 445 kilojoules per
mole.
That's this number that I
calculated right here.
This is the bond strength,
445 kilojoules per mole.
That's the bond strength in the
sodium chloride molecule.
That's how much energy is going
to be required to take sodium
chloride and pull it apart,
into the neutral atom sodium
and the neutral atom chlorine.
That is physically what that
number is.
But now what did I say earlier?
I said that sodium ejects an
electron which ends up on the
chlorine.
And if that is the case,
that is if that sodium ejects
an electron that ends up on the
chlorine and it does it when the
sodium and the chlorine are far
apart, that's going to require
147 kilojoules per mole.
That is what we calculated
there.
That is this number.
That is 147 kilocalories
uphill.
So if sodium and chlorine are
really far apart,
that is how much energy it is
going to require to pull that
electron off of sodium and put
it onto the chlorine.
This is IE, ionization energy
minus the electron affinity.
I said that that happens when
it is far apart,
but now the sodium ion and the
chlorine ion come together.
They come together to the bond
length.
And at the bond length they
form this chemical bond.
And when they form this
chemical bond,
well, then what we have
released is this much energy,
minus 592 kilojoules per mole.
Now, where did this number come
from?
Well, that number comes from
the following simple model.
That number comes from the
potential energy of interaction
between a bare plus charge and a
bare minus charge at r equals
2.36 angstroms.
This is the potential energy of
interaction for a plus charge
and a minus charge,
so it's minus e squared.
r here is this bond length,
2.36.
If you evaluate that at r
point, 2.36, you will get 592
kilojoules per mole.
So what did I do here?
I treated sodium ion and
chlorine ions like two bare
point charges.
I forgot about the fact that
sodium here has got other
electrons.
I forgot about the fact that
chlorine here has got other
electrons.
I just approximated it as two
point charges and used the
Coulomb interaction between a
bare plus charge and a bare
minus charge to get this energy,
592 kilojoules per mole.
That is where that comes from.
So when the sodium and chlorine
come together to this bond
length, well,
then they form a bond and this
much energy is released within
this model here.
So we're beginning to
understand what all these
numbers are and physically what
is going on, except maybe what
is still bothering you is the
fact that it still looks like,
in order for this reaction to
go, that I've got to put in 147
kilojoules per mole into the
reaction before I am going to
get any energy back.
It kind of looks like there is
a barrier to this reaction from
what I've told you so far.
But the answer is,
there isn't,
because when the electron jumps
is not when the sodium and the
chlorine are infinitely far
apart.
But when the electron jumps is
when the sodium and chlorine are
right here at this value of r
star.
Why right here?
Well, it happens right here
because of this.
This blue line here,
see this blue line?
What that is the Coulomb energy
of interaction as a function of
r between two point charges,
plus 1 and minus 1.
So way out here,
when r is very large,
that energy of interaction for
these two ions is zero.
But as these two ions come
closer together,
that energy of interaction
becomes more and more negative.
There is a 1 over r dependence
here.
And that is what that blue line
approximates.
At some point that Coulomb
interaction energy crosses this
black curve here which
represents the interaction
energy between a neutral atom
and a chlorine atom.
Right here, the Coulomb
interaction energy is the energy
difference between up here to
down here.
Right here, this is the Coulomb
interaction energy minus e
squared 4 pi epsilon nought
at r star now,
not equilibrium
distance.
At r star where the electron
jumps.
Right here, this Coulomb energy
of interaction equals this
energy difference between the
two separated ions and the two
separated atoms.
This energy difference here
measured from here to here is
minus the ionization energy
minus the electron affinity.
So right here this electron can
jump and it doesn't cost us any
energy.
Because the Coulomb interaction
has already set in.
Right here that Coulomb
interaction energy is equal to
this energy difference.
That is when the electron
jumps, right here.
And then it is at that point
that the sodium and the chlorine
are accelerated together up to
the equilibrium bond length form
of bond and you have the sodium
chloride molecule.
Let's calculate what this value
of r star is.
At what value of r does this
electron actually jump?
Well, we can do that.
This is minus e squared over 4
pi epsilon nought r star.
That is going to be equal to
minus the quantity ionization
energy of sodium minus the
electron affinity of chlorine.
Let me rearrange this here.
I am going to solve for r star.
r star is equal to e squared
over four pi epsilon nought
times the quantity ionization
energy of sodium minus the
electron affinity of chlorine.
r star is equal to e squared,
e squared is 1.602x10^-19
Coulombs squared over four pi
epsilon nought,
you can look up epsilon nought,
times this difference in
energy.
The ionization energy of sodium
minus the electron affinity of
chlorine, which way over here we
said was 147 kilojoules per
mole.
So let me put that into joules
so my units are consistent,
1.47x10^5 joules per mole.
But now, be careful here.
When you calculate r star,
this is for a molecule.
Not for a mole of molecules.
I've got to change all of these
things that are in here per mole
to molecules,
so I have got to multiply this
by 6.022x10^23 molecules per
mole.
And then the value of r star is
equal to 9.45x10^-10 meters.
That is when the electron
jumps.
Let's draw a picture of what
actually the relative size is
here.
So we have a sodium atom.
That sodium atom has a diameter
of about 3.8 angstroms.
And we have a chlorine atom.
That chlorine atom has a
diameter of about two angstroms.
It is 9.45 angstroms.
That is the distance between
those two neutral species,
when that electron jump process
actually happens.
So they are pretty far apart,
pretty far apart compared to
the bond length of 2.36
angstroms.
And, indeed,
it turns out that this number,
9.45 angstroms is very,
very close to what is measured
experimentally when that
electron jump process happens.
This simple model treating
sodium and chlorine as point
charges works,
but it works because sodium
chloride is a very ionic bond.
This simple model will not work
for bonds that are not very
ionic.
All right?
Okay.
See you Friday.